hi friends this week were talking about
happiness the field of psychology for a
very long time was focused on making bad
people okay as opposed to okay people
better or happy people even more happy
I'm happy to sit down pardon the pun
with Susanna Hallinan who is the world's
first happy ologist she is a positive
psychology specialist the author of
happiness is here and screw finding your
passion she's a published researcher
TEDx speaker online columnist and a
regular commentator in the media from
the BBC to The Huffington Post and more
and we're gonna try and find out how I
become a little bit happier in life I
was incredibly surprised at how many
basic steps we can take in our
day-to-day life to actually make our
level of happiness a baseline level of
satisfaction improved it it was very
enlightening and there was a lot of new
information that came out of this now
one of the key tools that Suzanna
suggests that everybody should be using
is a journal and I know that I will be
asked for some advice on which journal I
recommend which one I use so the six
minute diary which have mentioned on
numerous life hacks the podcast with
Warren Kass and the podcast with you and
Lawson will be linked in the show notes
below it's my favorite way to develop a
journaling habit three minutes on the
morning three minutes in the evening
with prompt for questions susana gives
you a lovely little program that you can
follow as well on a weekly and a daily
basis you can add those in I've chosen
to as there are sections in the diary to
add weekly notes as well if you follow
the link in the show notes below you
will be supporting this channel at no
extra cost to yourself
so please do so if you want to start
journaling consider using the six minute
Diaries it's my favorite now let's chase
after some happiness
[Music]
susannah Hallinan welcome to modern
wisdom yeah thank you so much thank you
so much for having me fantastic how are
you yeah I'm very good I'm feeling good
the the sun is shining I've had a good
start to the week so yeah it's all good
brilliant so let's get straight into it
can you tell me what a happy ologist is
please yeah basically as my job as the
happy ologist my mission in life is to
make the world a happier place and the
way I do that is anything from
one-to-one coaching work to workshops to
keynote talks at organizations and I've
recently started also doing more online
courses on it and some books as well and
it's basically just all about helping
you to live a happier and more
fulfilling life in short yeah okay well
it sounds like a a pretty noble pursue I
suppose yeah I mean I I love it I it's
it's amazing very fulfilling yes it is
absolutely is and it is really the
opposite almost of what I used to do
because I haven't always been the happy
ologist so I went initially into the
corporate career doing well a mix of
things from project management to
marketing communications to PR and very
quickly realized it wasn't quite the
world for me and also I felt it wasn't
meaningful enough for me so I felt like
I wanted to connect to the work that I
was doing more and feel like what I was
doing was beings making some kind of
positive impact and when I discovered
positive psychology I just had this
epiphany moment that that that was it
that was kind of the thing that would
help me to help others as well that was
your calling in life right yes
absolutely
that's fantastic I've seen you've done
TEDx speaking you commentator from BBC
to Huffington Post as well so the a
subject area as happy ology which I
guess is not tremendously mainstream
it's obvious that there's a demand for
your your work in your talent
yeah absolutely and it's I think it's a
it's a growing field as well so how I
kind of got into it is initially just my
you know exploring positive psychology
with books and blogs and people in the
field and then eventually I want to do a
Masters of Science in it because I
really wanted to specialize myself in
the actual science behind it and I mean
the University where I went to do it was
the University of East London and that
was only the second university to offer
positive psychology as a master's of
science so is yours Masters of Sciences
in positive psychology in applied
positive psychology oh okay okay yeah so
I mean if there was ever someone who had
the natural passion and then the the
academic backing to deploy this sort of
research and this sort of knowledge I
guess that's the perfect storm for
yourself right yeah absolutely
absolutely and I think also because when
I was you know going through my
corporate career and trying to figure
out you know what was wrong and why
wasn't I happy and why was I so
unfulfilled I think that's also one of
the things that attracted me to positive
psychology so when I went to study it
initially basically to use it to help
other people
I also obviously tested every exercise
in every tip and every practice on
myself so through that I was able to
transform myself as well and take that
journey myself that I now take my
clients through and I really managed to
go from a natural pessimist to a trained
optimist and it's yeah it was an
incredible journey and it's yeah it was
very worthwhile
okay so you've touched on something
there that I really wanted to ask you
can you tell us how much of our level of
happiness is nature and how much of it
is nurtured so well when we talk about
external versus internal things when it
comes to our happiness according to
research on average only about 10% of
our happiness is predicted by external
thinks or environment things like I
don't know the job we're in
the neighborhood we live in the
relationship we're in everything that's
outside of us that's really only 10% of
our happiness and 90% is entirely up to
you now obviously in that 90% there are
some genetics at play so our kind of
family history in terms of mental health
and well-being
does have some influence but there's a
huge chunk is basically just about our
perspective and how we choose to
approach life Wow
so you are broadly in control yes
absolutely
absolutely and that's why I always say
happiness is is not it's not a
destination that we get to when we get
that perfect job or dream house or
amazing relationship no because yes of
course when we get those things we get a
sense of achievement and pride and we
get excited but after you get those
things you quickly adapt back to that
same mood setpoint that you were in
before and it's actually about learning
to choose happiness on a daily level
because happiness is not a destination
it is a daily choice and the way you
make that daily choice is by really
learning to embrace your mindset and
your perspective and really practice an
attitude of gratitude on a daily level
hopefully we can try and lay out a
framework for some of the listeners to
be able to follow that today so you
briefly mentioned it there I want to ask
is that what you've just discussed with
regards to chasing the house and it not
being the fulfillment and then the reset
is that hedonic adaptation yeah pretty
much because that's the thing we're
chasing all these things I mean there is
a little bit of a demonic happiness
there a little bit because when we're
chasing goals and we're growing and
challenging ourselves and pushing
ourselves whenever we're growing and
evolving we naturally get a sense of
purpose since a sense of meaning also
because we know kind of why we're doing
what we're doing but I think the mistake
is that then we think well when we get
that that's it that's that's the kind of
end and then we're there and we're
permanently happy when usually when we
just get to that goal we just set
another one and another milestone and
something else to reach for which of
course is good because then you are
striving and pushing yourself but the
steak is that then like you say you just
adapt to the circumstances and you're
like oh I'm not happy with what I have
anymore
I will need more to be happy the next
winning house the name exactly exactly
when in fact if we just learn to kind of
appreciate the now every day regardless
of what you have or where you are still
keep striving for those goals but still
learn to kind of enjoy that journey and
every step of the way towards them do
you think that the do you think it's a
difficult task for someone to be
grateful and feel satisfied with what
they have which it would appear you say
you're alluding to helps to manifest
happiness whilst also keeping themselves
hungry for that drive to get more you
understand how that that could seem
conceptually to be to two opposites yeah
but I think it's just about finding the
right balance because you can still have
goals and you can still have milestones
and you can still appreciate the journey
towards them so being grateful for what
you have doesn't mean that you don't
grow or learn or push yourself or go
after the things you want it doesn't
mean you stay at status quo and never
strive for anything it just means that
whenever you are faced with a challenge
or a setback or a failure you're still
able to see the positives you can see
that as a learning opportunity and then
you can almost use that as fuel to keep
going and also on those days when maybe
you are feeling a little bit more low or
sad or stressed then you can swoop in
with gratitude and actually pay
attention to all the good things that
you do have in your life as well so it
is really all about finding kind of that
perfect balance between being content
and fulfilled with what you have whilst
also pushing yourself to grow and
involve as well yeah I think that must
be a very difficult balance for a lot of
people I know looking at my own
experience that a lot of the time I I
can sometimes or in the past I have not
allowed myself to be as grateful or as
thankful for things that have gone on
because in the back of my mind I think
I've thought well if I get comfortable
with this my drive to improve he's going
away
I'm somehow going to become complacent
and that's going to that's going to
prevent me from continuing to chase down
my dreams so to speak hmm and I think I
think that's definitely definitely
something that a lot of people will be
dealing with so before we get into it
can you define being happy or can you
define happiness yeah well basically if
you kind of summarized it in positive
psychology terms happiness equals in
short pleasure plus purpose and what I'm
talking about pleasure so that's
simplifying that whole hedonic happiness
side of the equation which is all about
short-term positive emotions things like
savoring delight laughter joy
contentment all of those things and then
purpose is all about having that sense
of meaning so that's more tied to a
demonic happiness and that gives more of
a long-term sustainable type of
happiness that fulfills you in a
completely different way so if you're
able to understand what brings you here
donek happiness or those short-term
bursts of positive emotions and also
what gives you a demonic happiness so
that sense of purpose that sense of why
connecting to yourself feeling like
you're fulfilled in the life that you
live then those two things are what
basically make happiness happen for you
Wow so you've got these two very
distinct elements presumably there's an
interplay between the two with in the
same way as someone's training schedule
will consist of both training and
nutrition and the two interplay between
each other but above distinct as well
yes in order to chase down the goal of
happiness you need to have both of these
yeah absolutely that's I mean it makes
sense it's not something that I thought
I directly knew but it definitely makes
sense that there's these two elements to
it yeah so what's the framework that you
begin to give people to turn that
concept of two different kinds of
happiness how do they begin to implement
that in their lives or chase it down to
manifest it yeah well I think before I
even start talk to them about hedonic
happiness I encouraged them to turn
gratitude into habit because when you're
able to have an attitude of gratitude
that's when you're can actually totally
rewire your brain and you start to see
things differently you start to notice
things differently so the first exercise
I give all my clients is a gratitude
journal which is basically finishing
every single day by writing down three
specific things that you were most
grateful for in that specific day and
the really key there is to make sure
that they are specific so it's not just
I'm grateful for my family I'm grateful
for my job I'm grateful for the Sun no
it has to be really specific like I'm
grateful for a lovely Skype call I had
with my brother who lives in a different
country so so the thing is with the
gratitude exercise is to make sure that
they are really specific to that day and
then to keep doing that gratitude
exercise every evening at least for 21
days if not longer basically when you
start to notice yourself going into your
day looking for things to be grateful
for like oh I could put that in my
journal later ooh that could go in and
that could go in that's when you know
that it's starting to work that's when
you know you're starting to learn to
focus more on the positives on the
things that you can be grateful for and
you can start approaching life which
more if this sense of awe and wonder
that children for example approach it
with and once you start getting your
mindset into that kind of place that's
when it's a lot easier to start
exploring these questions of hedonic and
your demonic happiness like what is it
that actually brings me joy and what is
it that brings me your demonic happiness
also because then you can look back in
your gratitude journal and you will
probably start to see common
denominators and patterns right exactly
exactly so that's always kind of the
first step I encourage people to take
when it comes to them shifting into into
a more positive place regardless of
what's going on around them
but really starting to focus on on
working on that inner mindset is that is
attitude the foundation upon which
happiness is built then to a degree yes
yeah absolutely because without
gratitude it's it's very difficult to
see the light in a lot of things you
know because gratitude leads to anything
from being able to be more creative to
productive to being able to think of
more solutions being able to focus on
the good appreciate the people in your
life deal with stress more effectively I
mean it just goes on and on in terms of
the benefits of gratitude because you
really start to approach things from a
completely different angle yeah well I I
like the fact that you've you've brought
up stuff to do with habits we spend a
lot of time talking about habits on the
show and I swear that you were you
aren't reading my notes but there is how
can have it to impact happiness a little
bit further down my nose we're gonna
come back to that in a little bit but I
think the the litmus test of are you
starting to see things during your day
that you want to become grateful for
that you you see can um will feature
potentially in the journal or in your
diary later on in the day I think that's
a really nice way to put it
I used this example previously but one
of my friends was talking about his
training and he was saying that he was
not getting enough sleep and he was not
getting enough food at the moment and
his training wasn't optimal and I've
been journaling for a little while and
his approach to that was I'm not optimal
I'm not in my best I'm not prepared
myself the best to go in and train then
therefore I can afford to write training
off to a degree and we had it we had a
conversation about it and he was a
little bit down and my approach to it
which surprised myself because this
isn't my tittle this wouldn't have
usually been my typical way of looking
at it my way to look at it was to say
well look mate you have the opportunity
here to conduct training sessions under
duress and under non ideal circumstances
this is an opportunity so that if you go
into a competition and you know you
haven't slept sufficiently well you know
that you haven't eaten well maybe you've
travelled maybe what Evers happened you
know that you've still got it in the
tank so this is an opportunity for you
to be grateful for yeah okay maybe it's
not ideal but how can we flip that on
its head and actually make it into what
rather than a negative yeah I think for
me that was a very small but really
stark identifier that the journaling
practice have just completed five months
yesterday amazing so I've finished my
first one I've had to get a new one and
this happens to be the third podcast in
a row where we've brought up journaling
so the one that was released just last
week with dr. Ewen Lawson author of the
healthy writer that he he sang the
praises of journaling and I think when
you've got so many different so many
people from different fields all of whom
are converging over the top of a a
single habit I think for anybody who's
listening who isn't journaling and isn't
doing gratitude I think that that's a
it's definitely a good place to start so
you're talking about three things on an
evening that people are grateful for and
that is beginning to form the foundation
is that right yes absolutely
definitely great where do we go from
there so from there I think like you
said we can start once we've done it for
a couple of weeks we can start looking
at those patterns and then we can start
actually exploring those two questions
about what is it that actually makes you
feel joy in those short-term moments of
positive emotions and on the other side
what does that gives you that sense of
meaning because especially when it comes
to sense of meaning and that Y and that
purpose a lot of people tend to get
overwhelmed with the idea that in order
to have purpose in your life you're
supposed to be curing cancer abolishing
poverty or solving some massive
humanitarian cause and it's like well no
actually the definition of purpose is
just you knowing why you do what you do
so as long as you understand why what
you're doing has actually some kind of
outcome or purpose or is somehow
meaningful to you that's good enough and
I think yes it's still good to explore
the whole if you want to have some kind
of positive impact you know you want to
leave your mark on the world but we have
to start small because those big
questions can be really overwhelming
especially if we haven't really explored
it before it's really just start by
looking at your daily actions you know
brushing your teeth oh why do I brush my
teeth
oh well I can have hell
the tea it's like you know why did I go
to the gym or go for a walk in the park
well it's good to exercise okay and it
makes me feel good okay I get it right
you're going to work mode okay why am i
doing
I don't know this report for my manager
oh it's because he needs it to show to
the board or the team or whatever okay
so that's the why behind that because
once you just start asking yourself
right why am I doing this then you start
to connect to all those different
actions on a daily level in your life
and at your work and you can actually
start to create more of that sense of
meaning and purpose without daunting
yourself with that massive question
what's my life purpose goal right yeah
to bring it back to the listeners the
listeners are going to know what I'm
going to say to bring it back to Jordan
Peterson one of the exercises that he
uses is clean up your room I'm not sure
if you've heard him talk about this no I
haven't actually right so he the first
thing that he gets a lot of his patients
to do is to begin to clean up their room
and what he says is that your bedroom is
a domain of competence that you broadly
most people generally speaking will have
control over there are very few people
whose bedrooms are so out of control
they couldn't tame it themselves and the
point is that you start off by getting
control over a domain of competence that
is within your capabilities and then
once the room is clean then you can look
right okay maybe maybe I can try and do
the bathroom maybe I can try and do the
kitchen okay well my friends got
something going on with their house with
their life with their and as you begin
to clean up the small things first you
build a brick on top of a brick on top
of a brick and before you know it it's a
wall which is your capacity to overcome
things but also also the domain of
competence grows so what become what
gets included within that web of what
you're trying to take on also becomes
broader and I think that the starting
small starting at finding what am i
doing now why is it giving me purpose
what is the why is the larger
perspective looking at these tasks
I think that that sort of ties across
really nicely yeah absolutely and that's
just it like you said like all those
tiny little steps do end up building
that massive fortress in the end but
it's just about really breaking it down
and taking the time doing the tiniest
thing you can do are asking that tiniest
why question and then that's how you can
start building it up because also with
kind of every step forward and every
question that you kind of answer you get
more of that sense of confidence as well
and more of that fulfillment so then you
want to do even another step and even
another step so each step kind of fuels
the next one as well yeah I really
wanted to ask this question actually
you've just touched on it there can you
explain how confidence and Happiness
into play yeah I mean they're completely
interlinked so happier people are more
confident and also the more confident
you tend to be the happier you feel so
it is kind of like this positive spiral
and a lot of it is to do with because
when you feel confident with yourself
that's when you kind of believe in
yourself you have a sense of you know
self love and self compassion and you
appreciate that you have certain you
know abilities and strengths and
qualities and traits and talents that
you are meant to share with the world
and when you have that sense of
confidence within you you're naturally
gonna show up more as who you are
wherever you go so naturally you're
gonna be living a life that's much more
aligned with who you are which again is
another kind of driver of happiness
because you're not trying to build a
life by being somebody who you're not or
just being trying to be somebody who you
think you should be but if you have that
natural sense of confidence you tend to
really connect to your values to your
truth and build a life according to them
so naturally that is also gonna fuel
fuel your happiness and unfulfilled
Montagna levels yeah that's that's
really interesting again to draw draw
across to something else
Jordan Pete's and talks about rule
number seven of his 40 rules for life is
tell the truth in fact no it's not it's
real number one I can't
well yeah rule number one tell the truth
and rule number three act so that you
can tell the truth by how you act yeah
and so you'd mentioned there that people
should start to take pride in the things
that they do
I can imagine I can hear some of my more
negative friends already saying well I
have nothing to be proud of I'm not
proud of anything that I do in my life
what do we say to that well we tell them
to dig deeper basically if we don't I
can't be confident I can't be confident
because I have no confidence because I
don't do anything which is of value to
me so this is when I think it's really
important to be surrounded by
cheerleaders so these are kind of you
know your your dream tribe around you so
people who really support you and
encourage you and you know if you have a
friend who's a little bit like that or
is having a rough day or it's just not
seeing not able to see any of their
successes or achievements that's when
it's kind of your opportunity to also
step up and say look I do you think
you're being realistic about this and
then just point out certain things like
what about that time when I don't know
you spoke up to your manager and said
actually could I change the way this is
done because I think it's more
productive or that time when I don't
know they succeeded in a fitness
challenge anything just anything goes
and I think it's also then about
bringing it back to to you and your
relationship with them and talk about
what actually I think you're an
incredible friend you've always been
really supportive and encouraging and
again try and give concrete examples as
much as possible because then you can
start to help kind of see it in a
different way because that's also how I
talk to some of my clients who maybe
have had or have currently have some
confidence issues and they can't really
see anything positive and are being a
bit too self-critical you know I really
try and ask them to try and turn
themselves try and put yourself in the
shoes of your best friend who's always
supported you encouraged you and loved
you and what would they say to you right
now
you know what is it that they would want
you to hear in this moment of your doubt
because then you can really step in
you can start exploring no they are
actually positives of play okay there
was this time where I was successful or
this time that I did well or this time
when I helped somebody and again I am
try and really look for the tiniest
little things and when you start
exploring it and thinking about it then
more and more will come out but it's
just about making sure you really push
your brain really to work hard on this
and and just really think of as many
examples as possible because initially
you might come up with the most obvious
ones but then you just say okay what are
three more examples what are three more
examples and just keep pushing and
pushing and then eventually they'll be
like okay they'll they might look back
on their list or that conversation that
you've had and be like okay fair enough
maybe there are some times that you know
I have done things well and I have been
successful and okay I can I can recreate
more of that etc yeah I think having
done the having to my gratitude
journaling for quite a while now it's
strange to see what it is that I find a
value to myself I think after a little
while these patterns begin to emerge as
you said and they're not necessarily
always the things that you think they're
not you know it's never I've never
written in my gratitude journal at the
end of the day I'm grateful for getting
two thousand likes on a prawn who
thought or what incident yes
that's never appeared and I think a lot
of the time what what that's led to
happening is for me to look at where I'm
spending my time during the day and then
what it is that I'm valuing on a night
and I'm seeing quite a contrast between
the two at times all I'm trying to close
it close the gap as best I can I'm
sometimes especially early on the amount
of time and effort that was being
invested in the things which at the end
of the day wouldn't wouldn't even
feature in the periphery of what could
enter the grachi journal was it just
meant well why am i spending my time
doing that yeah what it's not fulfilling
me it's not making me feel any better
it's when I'm alone with my thoughts at
the end of the day just before I go to
bed and I'm writing in what were the
best parts of
day it's it's not there so when the day
starts afresh again tomorrow
maybe maybe think about not doing it
yeah absolutely absolutely and I think
it's really good to do that kind of
self-reflection on a continuous basis
because as a human being you're
naturally evolving daily and you are
very dynamic from every level and that
means that sometimes these things can
also shift so maybe things that you
thought were really important to you I
don't know five years ago maybe you've
still kept doing them and then you
realize them today actually I'm not
connecting with them anymore and that's
when you need to check in and say okay
maybe this is something that I shouldn't
be doing anymore so it's about
constantly checking in with yourself
your actions your values all those
things so that you can really understand
okay
what is it that's fueling my fulfillment
and am I basically doing enough of it on
a daily level yeah I couldn't agree more
so we've got the gratitude that we're
doing on a daily basis we've started to
look at the things that we know can give
us the small things that we know can
give us purpose day to day yeah where do
you take it from there so then I would
really encourage people to practice
resilience and again that's something
that both of these things fuel anyways
so the more grateful you are the more
optimistic you are the more resilient
you tend to be and when I talk about
resilience it's it's not about being
stubborn minded and things like that and
just sticking with things that you know
I don't like for you know it's about
understanding that when you are faced
with a setback or a challenge or some
kind of failure it's there for a reason
it's there as an opportunity for you to
check in with yourself for you to grow
for you to push yourself out of your
comfort zone for you to develop and when
I talk about resilience I talk a lot
about growth mindset by Carol Drac have
you heard of that I've heard of it but
not read it yeah so basically yeah it's
I it's one of the I think one of my
favorite books from my studying times it
was incredible and it really completely
shifted my mindset and she talks about
basically
two ways to approach life when it comes
to your mindset so you can have a fixed
mindset or a growth mindset and if you
have a fixed mindset you basically think
that your abilities your trades your
intelligence is fixed and that's it
that's what you've kind of been gifted
with and that's what you have to work
with and you just carry on with that
whereas somebody with a growth mindset
sees their trade skills intelligence
abilities something that they can always
develop and that oh they can always
evolve and they can always grow in now
when it comes to you facing different
situations obviously there are certain
situations that can maybe put you more
in a fixed mindset and other ones that
can push you more into a growth mindset
but the important bit is to really try
and again be aware of this and see kind
of where you think you fit in the scale
when you are faced with a challenge
because if you are able to harness a
growth mindset that's when you start
seeing those challenges as opportunities
to grow and learn you start seeing other
people's success as inspiration not
threat you really start taking feedback
in a positive way and realize okay this
is an opportunity for me to grow rather
than taking it personally and thinking
this is just an attack on you and that's
why I think when it comes to resilience
and really being able to face all the
challenges and all the unplanned
surprises that we have on a daily basis
right exactly so I think it's really
important to try and harness that growth
mindset and whenever you are faced with
that challenge or that some kind of
setback just have a look at it you know
think of it okay how am I starting to
approach this challenge right now am I
going more into the negative or the
positive am I thinking fixed mindset or
you know fixed mindset way or growth
mindset way and then start diving into
it and I know okay this is an
opportunity for me to grow this is an
opportunity for me to learn this is an
opportunity for me to kind of really
step in and and and be a better version
of myself and one thing that can also
help you kind of get more comfortable in
a way in feeling more resilient is also
looking back on some of your past
setbacks and failures and then ask
yourself you know how is your life
or how are you better because of those
setbacks because in some way in one way
or another there will be some kind of
learning and growth in them and taking
the time to really pause and reflect on
that can can help kind of bring more of
that growth mindset in and also help you
to change face future challenges in a
better way as well okay so that's taking
it a little bit of a step further than
just the gratitude its reflection period
generally yeah so do you encourage your
clients and your patients to to take
these two period eyes reflection yeah
well I encourage if you can at the end
of every week to basically answer three
questions and again you can do
journaling or you can talk to somebody
about it you can just think about it I
mean again I'm a huge fan of journaling
so I always recommend that because also
putting stuff out on paper kind of helps
you digest them in a more effective way
but the three questions are is basically
one what was the one thing that I'm most
proud of from the last week the second
question is what is one learning that
I've had in the last week and the final
is what is the most beautiful moment
I've had in the last week so it kind of
again touches on all those different
elements of okay what is it that I'm
proud of how can i connect to that sense
of achievement and and connect to my my
self and my truth and feel more of that
compassion and the second is all about
that learning so really about
understanding okay was there a setback
or a challenge or something that really
helped me to learn and what was that
learning that I can now take forward
with me and the final just reflecting on
one beautiful moment from that week
because I think we just generally don't
take enough time to just pause and
reflect on all the kind of amazing
things that are happening around us and
just picking one moment that you're kind
of going to spend some time extra time
savoring after it's happened can really
help to to boost not only those positive
emotions but also that sense of
fulfillment yeah I think so the the time
that you can spend to ruminate over
something which gives you pleasure in
inherently is it's very liberating and
it's like it's like free happiness
presuming that do you know I mean like
you've already done it you've put the
investment in the activity is gone and
you're now able to just revisit that in
your mind and elicit the same emotions
again yeah absolutely so I wanted to ask
a question that I think a lot of people
will think yeah is tackling unhappiness
the same as making people happy so in
CrossFit there is a spectrum of sickness
to wellness to fitness not sickness to
health to fitness so is this the same so
it depends pretty much how you define
unhappiness because obviously if you
have been diagnosed with clinical
depression it's a little bit of a
different ballgame and there are you
need to kind of be a little bit more
caution it about what kind of exercises
you do and you know work for the
clinical psychologist to help kind of
yourself work work on yourself with the
right tools because sometimes depending
on how in what kind of place you are
some of the tools if you struggle with
them they can make you feel worse I'm
gonna get the reflection period if you
if you're feeling really bad is just
going to send you the spiral the
echo-chamber that you mentioned before
of positivity is actually is actually
just going to bounce you off the walls
about all of the bad stuff exactly
because if you're not able to think of
the positives and then you start just
journaling or rather than ruminate about
all of the bad stuff yeah yeah
absolutely and then then I would
encourage you to think more of things
you can do with your body so things like
moving breathing smiling hugging you
know the power of pose just kind of
trying to almost trick your mind into a
more positive place by getting your body
into a more positive place as well and
also when it comes to positive
psychology for example it kind of got
born in a way I think it's been around
like just well yeah 20 just over 25
years now and it kind of became what it
is because the founding fathers Martin
Seligman and
and me like Mihaly Csikszentmihalyi they
said that traditional psychology is a
little bit too focused on kind of the
negative so how to get people from minus
five to zero whereas positive psychology
really focuses on how you get from zero
to plus five so you're already kind of
stable and you're kind of healthy
overall yes you can still worry and
stress and have anxiety and things like
this but you're in a place where you
feel kind of at least somewhat confident
that you are capable of working on
yourself and you believe most
importantly that you can get to a better
place and when you're in that place
that's when you can really start using a
lot of these positive psychology
exercises to to get to that happier
place yeah I understand that completely
I think to draw it back to the training
of the CrossFit analogy that is right it
is a spectrum of going from unhappiness
to Norma hadi at wherever you classes
normal to then happiness
in the same way as someone who's
sedentary and hasn't been training you
don't get them off the couch and then
try and get them a deadlift to 200 kilos
yes there's an on-ramp is to get them
through the spectrum the methodology is
different and the specifics are
different but the concept is the same
however there are stages of which people
need to be taken through right okay you
haven't moved you haven't moved for a
long time why don't we try and do ten
minutes of walking a day why don't we do
30 minutes of walking why don't we go
for a light jog why don't we begin to do
some weight training and in the same way
as there is a paradigm and within each
strata as people begin to move through
it they open up new exercises which they
can use and utilize in different ways
and probably dispense with old ones
there's none there's not many top level
CrossFit athletes who are probably
considering going for a 10-minute walk
because that's contributing to their
training yeah and in the same way as
people who have gone through the move
from depression to normality to
happiness don't necessarily need to go
back to the exercises they were doing to
stop their depression yeah yeah exactly
yeah that's really really interesting so
what
it's just is there anything else which
science says makes people happy which we
haven't covered so far yeah I mean well
there's a lot well I mean we've talked a
little bit about the body and obviously
with the CrossFit mentions that you've
made us well maybe it's it's it's good
to spend a little bit of time talking
about that and what we can do with our
body as well because as much as we think
you know our mind is driven is it
affects our body our body also affects
our mind and actually if we were able to
kind of nurture ourselves and take care
of ourselves and give our body the
things that we need from healthy
exercise to enough rest to the right
nutrition then we're you know already
starting in a better place but also when
it comes to specific exercises you can
do with your body physically to start
shifting your mindset into a positive
one I mean the most simplest one is
smiling and I mean it sounds ridiculous
and silly and a lot of people laugh
about it but there is a whole chemical
reaction that happens in your body when
you smile and actually even a fake smile
okay okay so that's that's true even
regardless of whether the smile listen
Judy being happy if you smile yeah your
body your mind will respond exactly
because that's when the dopamine is
returning all of those things can they
start flowing in your body and then you
actually start to feel better and then
you want to smile even more and the more
you smile the more if they go into your
body and again the better you feel so
even kind of forcing a fake smile can
help to stop make that shift and best of
all with the smiling it's also very
contagious so you know if you go to her
into a room and you smile at people you
not the mirror neurons in the back of
their brains or automatically get
activated and they immediately want to
reciprocate and smile back at you I mean
that's just something that
evolutionarily is something that happens
naturally without you thinking about it
so you have to try really hard not to
smile in somebody yeah so I think that's
just something to
to remind yourself off as simple as that
just smiling and know it's a double win
right you get the effect on yourself
plus you get the effect on other people
plus you get their reciprocated likeness
towards you yeah exactly exactly and it
builds more meaningful connections it
just fuels positive energy within you
and around you so it's it's really a
win-win-win in a way can you talk to us
about diet and its effect on mood and
Happiness yeah I mean the thing is with
diet if we don't get all the nutrients
into a body that we need you know the
vitamins the protein the carb or
everything we actually start depriving
of our body and our body naturally goes
into a state of stress and if her body
is enacted in a state of stress because
it's not getting what it needs and it
thinks it's in starvation mode or it's
not getting enough water it's
continuously dehydrated then that's when
it starts to kind of shut down some body
parts to try and preserve your energy
and one of the things that it starts to
shut down the first is actually your
mind so you actually have less power of
your brain and less capacity of your
brain power to use because your body is
thinking oh they haven't eaten well or
there aren't nutrients who maybe like
I'm in starvation mode okay I need to
preserve my energy I need to hold you
know things back and then you start
being less able to manage your thoughts
and also your emotions and being able to
think creatively because your body just
doesn't have the fuel it needs in order
to do that yeah I know
calorific Lee that the brain is
incredibly expensive it is for the body
I think it's something like 5% of your
weight but takes up 30% of your of your
energy or your calories yeah I think did
something along those lines
am I right in thinking that there's a
very high number of is it dopamine or
serotonin either receptors in the gut or
releases in the gut yes yes exactly that
as well so that when you're basically
digesting stuff and processing food you
need to also make sure that that's all
happening and and that's why that fuel
is just so important because like then
that would also then connect to the
smile and how effective the smile is big
obviously it's harder to smile if if you
don't have those things in a readily in
a ready state to function as well and
again they need that fuel to to really
keep going yeah definitely
so we've touched on a little bit of
exercise we need to get some people
moving if people that if people want to
be happier they can move more yes we
need to make sure we need to make sure
they're eating correctly yeah we want
them to be doing some gratitude
journaling we want them at the end of
the week to be asking themselves three
questions what about sleep what sort of
an impact does sleep have on mood yeah
sleep is massive as well because the
only time that your body has the time to
recover is is during sleep you know
that's when your cells are regenerating
if you've you know done hard workouts
and things like that your muscles are
recovering and recuperating and also
whatever you've kind of gone through in
the day before you know learning or
challenges or creative thinking at night
when you're asleep your brain is
actually hard at work because it's
digesting all of that it's creating new
neural pathway there are new neurons
forming so your brain is also again it's
a time in that time when you are asleep
in your mind physiologically your body
is actually working quite hard to get
everything back in place and recovered
so that you're ready for the next day so
I mean research kind of suggests that
ideally on average you should be getting
between seven to nine hours of sleep
every day now it does vary individual to
individual but that is the ideal on an
average and they also recommend that you
should try and have a similar sleep time
routine so basically go to bed
approximately same time and get up and
then morning the next day approximate at
the same time because that's when your
body again going back into habits your
body starts to understand when it needs
to start kind of winding down and
getting ready for bed and equally in the
morning then it knows oh okay
we're approaching I don't know 7 a.m.
and ok it's time to start kind of
awakening and getting alert and again
the more you can follow also the the
kind of natural cycle of light the
better because of your cortisol levels
being highest in the morning winning
when you get up when the Sun has come up
that's also when your your
most alert and you're most kind of
creative and productive so if you can
you should try and really use as much of
the daylight as you can and obviously it
depends where you are and how much
daylight you have I mean I come from
Finland and in the winter in the North I
think there's about two hours of
daylight it's you can't really sleep the
rest of the time yeah exactly but as
much as you can you should try and kind
of look at nature as well and look at
that cycle and see if you can match with
that as much as possible yeah throwing
your circadian rhythm into chaos is a
surefire way to start to decrease your
mood so I'm a I'm a club promoter and I
have been for twelve years which means
that for probably for the last six to
seven years at least three nights a week
I've gone to bed after 4:00 in the
morning and the that's a non-negotiable
I can't change that about my job so it's
been a long an arduous process for me to
work out strategies of how I can
mitigate that yet it's for a very very
long time I was it was very harsh on
myself about why are you getting up late
why are you so tired why you weren't
able to perform at the level that you
want to either in work or in
relationships or in the gym or wherever
it might be yeah
when not giving myself enough credit for
the fact well you weren't a bed at 4:00
in the morning after working a 20-hour
day I give you some a break
yes it's sleep sleep is one of those
things I think people always believe or
where you can just man up you know like
you'll be sweet yeah I'll sleep when I'm
dead that's I mean yeah holy holy
terrible advice because you're going to
be more unhappy and you're gonna die
sooner yeah exactly exactly and I think
you you brought up a really important
point there about kind of being kinder
to yourself as well you know being aware
of what's going on in your life and like
you're having like like you said 20-hour
days I mean oh my god of course you need
to just relax recharge and recuperate as
much as you can and I think that's again
another thing especially in today's
society where I think we seem to be
rewarded by busyness and the more we do
and
you know the better we seem to look to
the outside world and just having a pack
schedule and running from one place to
another and it's like well no that's
that's not what life is about it's
actually we need to kind of take more
time to nurture ourselves and spend some
quality time with ourselves and make
sure that we are in a happy healthy and
fit state because otherwise we don't
really have much left to give to others
either a hundred percent there's a a
couple of things that you've touched on
that I've spoken about recently and one
of them is to do with I use an analogy
in an Instagram post and I said why is
it that in an aeroplane which is going
down they ask you to put your oxygen
mask on before they ask you to put on
anybody else's and it's because if
you're suffocating your capacity to help
other people becomes drastically reduced
yes same thing the same thing talks true
here if you're not giving yourself time
and care and love even if you think
you're making the sacrifice of yourself
on behalf of someone else because they
need your time more you're restricting
how much of yourself you can give them
by not caring about yourself yeah
absolutely
I think that's yeah the a lot of this
appears to to come back to having more
compassion having more self compassion
again another Jordan Peterson rule for
life treat yourself as someone you are
responsible for helping yes you know
that that compassion is a really big
deal and I love the concept about people
seeing busyness as some marker for
perfect but I think busyness is being
conflated with purpose yeah and it's the
it's the one inch deep gossamer thin
veneer as opposed to actually looking at
what's underneath that and trying to fix
that problem or trying to work out what
what actually is meaningful to me well
I'm so busy I can't work out what's
meaningful to me my schedules so packed
I don't have time to reflect so you
don't have time to work out whether
something is good or bad because you're
just in so much chaos yeah you don't
have time yeah absolutely and it's like
that saying if you think you're too
dressed or too busy to meditate then you
should meditate twice as long yeah
because yeah I mean that's when you need
it the most and that's when you pray you
have to prioritize it even more as
difficult as it may seem but that you
have to it's like it's self-preservation
I mean it's it's survival it's a
non-negotiable I think for me yeah
especially a lot of what it's to do with
as well and and this comes back to the
domain of competence thing in the
building the brick one on top of another
there is a I can hold my hands up and I
can say that at some days in my life I
haven't had five minutes to be able to
stop but I can probably honestly
hormones up and say that there's never
been a day in my life where I haven't
had one minute and on headspace you can
meditate for a minute there's a button
it's on the home page and you can press
it and you can do it for one minute
and at the end of the day when I fill in
my habit bull checker yeah okay it's not
going to go down as a green which would
be fully completed it'll go down as a
yellow which means that it was a scaled
version well it's you know I mean like
it's logged on the board
like that's all that the brick hasn't
been taken away at the very least I
might not have added another one on but
I've not lost one no exactly I think
that building on top is is definitely
definitely a lovely way to look at it I
think that that little concept about
people confusing busyness with with
purposes gonna strike a chord if the
listeners who are those that maybe do
fill their schedules very very heavily I
think taking some time to think about
what how much do I actually enjoy what
I'm doing how much of what I'm doing is
just me being busy and how much of it is
me being happy yeah I think there's
probably going to be some some harsh
realizations so I want to talk about
happiness is here so you brought it you
brought a book out January this year yes
take us through it yeah so yeah so it's
called happiness is here and it's
basically a 30 day guide to joy in
fulfilment so it's the book basically
summarizes kind of the most
transformational tips when it came to
changing my mindset from a natural
pessimist to a trained optimist and me
kind of finding happiness and fulfilment
in my life so I was really keen to share
those tips with the rest of the world so
it is quite a personal story so I share
a little bit about where I was at
happiness at the start as in not very
happy and also when I went into positive
psychology and how kind of everything
that I learned there and continued to
learn even beyond my studies afterwards
still now today through life and through
you know coming across different things
it was really important for me to share
those learnings that were most helpful
for me and also have been most helpful
for my clients when it comes to just
yeah starting to bring more happiness
into your life and it must be it must be
such a you must have a wealth of things
to pick from and it must be quite
difficult to a degree because yeah
academically you understand the subject
matter anecdotally you understand your
own personal experience of it and then
professionally you understand how this
has been deployed to your clients so you
know I think if there was if there was
anyone that was gonna trust to give me a
program that I was going to follow to
try and become more happy I think that
you I think you definitely take all of
the boxes there yeah thank you that's
good so take us through some of the
things that you cover in the book yeah
so what some of the things we've
discussed today so in terms of what
happiness is basically this pleasure and
purpose that's or or or or they're all
kind of in there as well so kind of
debunking some of those myths around
happiness and there's also a lot about
kind of really understanding to connect
to yourself so there's a whole section
about you personally and your values and
just you learning to connect to your own
inner truth as well because the way I've
kind of structured is with these 30 days
so the idea is that every chapter it's
it's quite sure you can probably read it
in five to ten minutes at the end of
every chapter there's basically a tip
that you meant to practice on that day
and you know the first part is all about
those
penis truths and myths and then it's
about your unique happiness so
connecting to that purpose your values
what gives you hedonic happiness then we
start looking at your perspective so I
talk about gratitude they're a little
bit more deeply about optimism noticing
the beauty resilience all those things
that we've kind of touched on I also
look a little bit on relationships
because obviously as humans we are
social creatures so we not only need
each other to survive but actually to
thrive so I give a few tips on how to
make sure that you are connecting in a
more meaningful way with the people in
your life and how you're celebrating as
well those cheerleaders of yours that I
appreciate and I do also have a chapter
on decluttering some relationships
because I think sometimes we hold on to
people or relationships that maybe well
either need a breather or need some kind
of change and or they just simply don't
belong in your life anymore and I think
it's really important to take a kind of
harsh to look at some of them because if
there are people in your life that are
potentially holding you back or or being
toxic then it's it's important to try
and distance yourself from that because
you don't want them to start influencing
your happiness in a negative way and
then there's also a part about your body
you know where I talk again a little bit
more about smiling moving hugging power
pose and then my final part which I
think is my favorite is all about making
your happiness last and this is where I
talk about nurturing yourself reflecting
finding time to be still and also of
letting go of things that no longer
serve you so anything from your limiting
beliefs to objects to people kind of
just anything that you feel like it's
time to let go off now and I wrap up the
book with some tips about listening to
your heart and and your intuition as
well because that's that's another point
that I'm very very passionate about and
I think in today's society where we are
very mind reven and rational we've kind
of forgotten a little bit about the ha
and that gut feel and that intuition and
we forget that intuition knows so much
more than our mind does I mean our
intuition is basically connected to our
body our brain and every single
experience we've ever had in our lives
and we need to kind of learn to
reconnect with that because that again
is something that can really help guide
us when it comes to us on our path and
finding our truth and understanding what
is it that's meaningful to you and what
is it that you want to basically pursue
and how you want to live your life
that's really interesting so is is
intuition defined in the scientific
literature so I mean there's been some
attempts to define it I think that's the
the tricky thing with intuition is
because it it's very hard to measure
scientifically especially in psychology
terms I mean you can do subjective
surveys and things like that on what
people think is intuition inherently
very subjective right yeah exactly so it
hasn't gone much further than that but
equally I do believe it has a role to
play and I think that people are trying
to kind of find ways to measure it and
explore it but then at the same time
maybe it's just one of those things that
can't necessarily be explained with
science but it's just something that
what we know through feeling regardless
of whether or not the research or the
literature can define it everybody who's
listening understands what the
manifestation of that phenomenon is like
everyone understands what intuition
feels like and whether or not that can
be defined it is would be helpful but
but is a little bit secondary if we know
how to manipulate it hmmm so what I
really like about happiness is here and
one of the one of the reasons why
specifically for myself I'm looking
forward to implementing it is it's very
prescriptive to a degree that you have
things that you can follow it's got it's
got hard lines drawn in the sand so to
speak that are takeaways and then I
enjoy I enjoy reading personal
development and and self-help books
which are
actual and leave the door open for you
to apply the principles yourself I also
like being I like having things laid out
the mobility routine that I do ROM WOD
which I do every morning that is every
single day all I do is put my phone on
and I press a button and I do what the
[ __ ] I do what the video tells me to do
I like I like that element and I find
that when you're beginning a practice
and you know positive psychology and
taking moves people taking active moves
to make themselves more happy for the
for the sole goal of being more happy
not for it being because I'm gonna
profit off it not because I'm gonna be
more successful at work or whatever it
is for the sole goal of being happy
that's gonna be a big departure for a
lot of people from probably what they
would what they do on a daily basis I
can't imagine that the large majority of
people will wake up and think on a
morning while today I'm gonna work
really hard on being happy yeah which
which is actually you know probably
quite the wrong way to think about it
but yeah the the prescriptive element of
it the the rock-hard takeaways I really
really like I think some of the things
that we've gone through today I love the
framework that we've got hopefully we
can some of the listeners will be able
to employ these strategies and if they
want to take this further happiness is
here I'll make sure that the link is in
the show notes below can you tell the
listeners where they can find you online
yes of course so you can find me on my
website which is happy ologist
code at UK I'm also on social media as
at the happy ologist so the happy
ologists basically on Facebook Twitter
and Instagram and I also do a free
newsletter so if you want to sign up you
can do that on my website and yeah so
come and come and have a chat basically
you also do coaching online coaching for
clients as well right yes yes I do
online coaching I've got a new online
course actually coming up where I'm
working on a couple ones and yeah and
also those workshops and talks for
organizations and different types of
conferences and events
fantastic so thank you very much for
your time Susanna I'll make sure links
to a happy ology at UK your socials to
the book happiness is here plus screw
finding your passion which I know we
didn't even get round to maybe we're
gonna have to do another one we can talk
yeah we can go on talking about that but
thank you so much for today it's been a
fantastic chat I think a lot of people
will have taken away some really really
good concrete bits of advice that they
can implement in the lives
ya know thank you so much for for having
me it's it's been a blast and and I mean
this is my mission so I really love I
love sharing insights and yeah I really
hope that it's been helpful to your
listeners
I think we've definitely had an impact
today so thank you again thank you thank
you so much this is on
[Music]